[Applause]
shortly after the Vice Chancellors
resignation thousands of people gathered
at the Chancellery to express their
indignation with the far-right freedom
party and demand fresh elections and the
protesters got what they wanted
[Applause]
[Music]
chancellor sebastian courts announced
the end of his coalition saying the
populace freedom party had finally gone
too far after yesterday's video I must
honestly say that enough is enough the
Chancellor asked President Alexander
Fonda Belem to call snap elections the
president who can dissolve Parliament's
backed the move and had strong words for
the alleged corrupt deputy the leaders
of the Republic have broken the trust
placed in them this is outrageously
disrespectful to the citizens and I
cannot tolerate this lack of respect
snichlt this is the video behind the
scandal
Austria's Vice Chancellor Heinz
constructs are caught on tape apparently
soliciting campaign funding in return
for lucrative government contracts at a
meeting in a villa on the Spanish island
of Ibiza staffer thought he was talking
to the niece of a Russian oligarch in
addition to illegal donations they
discussed the possibility of her buying
a stake in Austria's biggest tabloid to
generate favorable coverage ahead of the
2017 elections but it was a sting and
the video was leaked to the media
all right let's get some more on the
story and for that we're joined by a
correspondent Bob basil who's standing
by in Vienna hello to you Barbara so do
we know yet when these fresh elections
in Austria are going to be held and what
would it mean what is it going to mean
for courts as a coalition government we
don't know yet when there will be
healthy selection Mariana but the likely
date is late September maybe even early
October because it takes more than six
weeks to prepare an election in Austria
more than a week to dissolve the
Parliament that is now sitting and
nobody does
something like this during the summer
vacation so plus you need a bit of time
for campaigning don't you so yes it's
likely that in early fall they're going
to be elections in Austria the morning
after the big demonstrations here is
still quite cancer course is just
meeting the president funda Balan and
they are talking about how to carry on
how this government can continue because
there are more contentious people in
cabinet the home of Affairs Minister for
instance Norbert Kiko who is really
highly sort of accused of being
extremely right-wing very similar to
what her car had struck it has been in
his party it's a very similar position
so can he stay on plus who is going to
be the know the new Vice Chancellor
that's a position that has to be by law
filled in Austria courts wants somebody
who is a sort of a third party
politician but the Freedom Party is
still fighting for their survival in
this government well Barbara of course
the very next election is the EU a
parliamentary election just a week from
now less than a week how much of a
setback is this scandal going to be for
Europe's far-right parties more broadly
this is going to be a big setback for
the freedom party because it is probably
going to be sort of reduced to is its
core its core clientele however in other
countries it's doubtful that this will
make big bay waves because populism is
region local regional and at best
national so Italian populist so where we
saw the big rally yesterday was material
salvini in Milan they are not going to
really look at Austria Plus already of
course conspiracy theories about the
sting operation on a visa and the the
whole the whole victim saga of are
already circulating they say oh we have
been victimized by other political
forces who want to destroy us we know
how this works is so it is probably not
going to have such a big effect in other
countries all right Barbara Veysel
reporting in Vienna thank you
[Music]